isaiah the tunisian president is
introducing a new constitution and put
it for vote at the referendum because
this has been always his political
project since he started
the political system is gonna move to
mainly a presidential system that is
the president is really executive power
even the prime minister is gonna be
chosen by the president regardless of
legislative elections so it's really
high concentration of power within the
president's hand
[Music]
the constitution is gonna have a new
point which is a little bit
controversial the relationship between
religion and state usually we tunisians
agreed that in the first clause of the
constitution we would have that the
tunisian state is islamic
introduced something new he introduced
in article 5
something about the objectives and goals
of islam and he mentioned five goals of
islam so for some this has been seen
as a more
islamicized version of the state and
this is in accordance with the
conservative background of eyesight
isaiah is deeply
conservative he's even competing with
political islam on the same electorate
one of the most controversial issues is
the way isaiah defines the different
powers but specifically the judiciary
path when we look back at the last month
his quarrel with the judiciary his
tendency to limit their power to
intervene in the judiciary that's an
indication of this expanding position of
the executive power in this constitution
one other goal his and he goes in
accordance with his populist ideology is
that the state
should serve the people and his
socialist semi-socialist view of the
economy is meant to be implemented by
this political system
[Music]
we cannot say that it's already an
authoritarian system but it's providing
the right ingredients for an
authoritarian system to develop i
wouldn't be surprised if we find a yes
with 80 90
and here this does not mean a total
support for the very simple reason of
how many people are gonna participate
there are
signs and indications
that the majority of people are not
really interested in these political
reforms as long as thai side is not
gonna tackle the economic and social
challenges the support towards him is
going to be limited and we may see signs
of social backlash and social
contestation of his legitimacy
[Music]
you